We Begin this hour with the historic
fight over the next house speaker and
who better to talk about it than
Republican Mick Mulvaney a CBS News
contributor and former acting white
house chief of staff in the Trump
Administration who also is a former
Congressman so he knows how this all
goes down and Joel Payne the CBS News
contributor and Democratic strategist
Republican leader Kevin McCarthy is
facing a major Revolt in his own party
this is the first time in 100 years at
the party in power has failed to elect a
speaker of the house in the first day of
voting this morning president Trump
called on Republicans to back McCarthy
on his social media platform saying in
part Kevin McCarthy will do a good job
maybe even a great job good morning
gentlemen good morning so how long can
we expect this to go in the mid-1800s
there were more than a hundred rounds of
voting how much should Americans buckle
up to listen to this and put up with
more of this and who do you think is
actually going to win how will this get
resolved Mick I'll start with you I
don't think anybody has any idea for how
long it's going to go on I think a lot
of them would like to see it end but
they can't figure out a way to to make
it end so it could drag out for several
days I think it's unlikely to go to
weeks but it could it could be that
who's the who's the winner keep in mind
what you've essentially got now is a
situation where any five or six
Republicans can get together and have a
veto over anybody so we ever talk about
Kevin he stopped by five or six people
say well Steve scalise is the next
guideline there's going to be five or
six people who object to him I think
that the only two possibilities are
either Kevin who's the really the
compromised candidate amongst
Republicans anyway or somebody that the
Democrats support with a small group of
Republicans I think that's the two most
likely outcomes Kevin or somebody that
the Democrats can prefer like former
representative Fred Upton from Michigan
yeah and look I I think that's possible
I guess what I would say is I don't
think Democrats are going to be looking
to do any favors for Kevin McCarthy for
House Republicans remember Kevin
McCarthy sold a lot of discontent so
would a lot of these members into
Congress encouraged them to run on these
Mega platforms so he could win these
seats but here's the thing during the
midterm cycle I think McCarthy knew he
needed his margins to be big he knew
that the only way he could really
guarantee himself the speakership is to
have a 20 30 40 seat margin in the house
because he knew that this element
existed so I think that in some ways
actually McCarthy showed that he could
count he just can't count to 218 this
week well so let me ask you about that
Mick uh of course Kevin McCarthy flew
out to Mar-A-Lago to get uh to take that
photo with President Trump uh after
January 6. the former president just
endorsed again Kevin McCarthy on Truth
social but I wonder these 20 or so
rebels in Congress that are not voting
for Kevin McCarthy they in part owe
their political careers to Donald Trump
and they don't seem to be listening to
him yeah it's really quite interesting
because some of them it's not just in
part I mean some of them he got them
across the line the reason they are on
Congress be is because of Donald Trump
and Donald Trump is supporting Kevin so
for to have them sort of thumb their no
knows is that Donald Trump I think just
sort of shows you how the president was
weakened by the midterms they sort of
like they really like Donald Trump but
they don't have to do what he says
anymore because he's not as powerful as
he was I think that's important and I
think the president the reason you saw
the the the social media post this
morning was he realizes he's going to
rise and fall here with Kevin McCarthy
he's not perceived as being as close to
Kevin as he was say with Herschel Walker
but he is perceived is his fortunes here
are tied to Kevin if Kevin loses it'll
be a loss for president Trump now Joel
the house cannot conduct business until
speaker is elected for those at home uh
that's you know which bills make the
floor shepherding must pass legislation
so what does that say about how we
govern this country because we can't
move forward with businesses well I
think it suggests that there is a chunk
of people in the house particularly of
mixed party who don't fundamentally
believe in governing right these folks
did not come to Washington with any
intent to govern and they don't want to
be a part of a governing scenario and
the fact that they are creating chaos is
actually the point like the the chaos is
the point I do think just taking a step
back here looking from the Democratic
perspective President Biden think about
what he's doing this week he's in
Kentucky today with a republican
governor of Ohio Mike dewine and Senate
Majority Leader I'm sorry Senate uh
Republican leader Mitch McConnell
talking about bipartisan infrastructure
accomplishments so you see The Branding
that President Biden is going into 2023
with and I can tell you talking to
senior Democrats this is the perfect you
know message to walk into 2023 and go to
2024 with we are here to do business
we're here to work with Republicans we
are here to be unifiers and Republicans
are showing they can't even pick their
own leader it's an interesting split
screen when you think about it like that
Mick what do you know about what's going
on behind closed doors they were surely
burning the midnight oil at the Capitol
last night what can you tell us uh yeah
I was in the building most of the day
yesterday
um it was in the on the in the chamber
for the vote and so forth and there's a
bunch of different Dynamics as you would
expect there's folks trying to put
pressure on the the never Kevin group
there is some discussion about what
happens if Kevin falters not much of
that yet because again I don't think
there's another Choice beside Kevin but
to your point about Democrats I was
taking the train over to the Senate
yesterday to talk to a friend of mine
who was getting sworn in in a very
prominent Democrat was passing me in the
hallway and he said so when are you
going to uh when are you guys going to
call us so that's the dynamic that's in
play here everybody knows but Mick that
and and Joel that is an interesting
fascinating nugget there that somebody
like Fred Upton could be a speaker that
Democrats rally around even though
they've said that they're going to stay
in that chamber until those votes happen
Fred Upton can go out tonight and say
look if you elect me speaker I won't do
any investigations I won't do any of
abortion or gay marriage legislation
support me and he could get 20
Republicans at every Democrat because
that's one of the things you could give
them is no investigations for the next
two years and Joel you're hearing that
that could happen I think it's possible
Hakeem Jeffries is not in any Rush again
to help Kevin McCarthy here but his
issues do matter to him so if there is a
compromise candidate that does allow
Democrats to protect the things that
they care about and forward the issues
they care about I think that is a
possible conversation also you got to
remember there are a lot of Democrats in
the house Democratic caucus who don't
think that the house necessarily works
well either you saw some videos of AOC
other Democrats who were kind of having
some strange bedfellow conversations
with folks like Matt Gates yesterday and
while they don't agree on anything one
thing they do agree on is that that body
has not worked the way they wanted it to
work quickly speaking of gays what do
you make of this statement if you want
to drain the swamp you cannot put the
biggest alligator in charge of the
exercise I think that says a lot about
the fractious nature of the GOP it's
it's a great one-liner but what it how
does it move the ball right direction
okay my response to Matt is okay Matt
that's fine so who do you want for
speaker and that was one of the
questions I kept asking these folks
yesterday is give me a name give me
somebody who who you don't like Kevin I
get it give me a name Jim Jordan who
doesn't want it and Jim Jordan who can't
get the votes I mean they're just not
possible again any Republican would have
to essentially faces a veto of any five
or six members so when you you can make
one-liners like that you could do real
well on social media you can get a lot
of media attention again a lot of these
folks have been on television more in
the last 48 hours that have been their
entire careers which really helps their
social media base their fundraising and
their chances of winning a Republican
primary but it doesn't move the ball in
the right direction good one liner I
don't know if I want to follow Matt
Gates politically down or dark alley I
would just say that all right Mick
Mulvaney Joe Payne always great to have
both of you here in studio thank you
very much and